se trata del sargento biden
marino un hombre de 21 años que
comandaba una unidad de tanques que
provenían de la región de moscú este
hombre hacía parte de una gran caravana
de vehículos blindados que veían venían
camino hacia quien al comienzo de la
guerra la región de schumi recibieron un
ataque y esta caravana se dispersó él
alcanzó a huir conjunto con cuatro
personas se dice que robaron un coche e
iban en una de esas poblaciones de la
región cuando vieron a un hombre
alexander cheli pop de 62 años que iba
en una bicicleta iba hablando por
teléfono ellos dicen haber pensado que
este hombre iba a delatarlos frente a
las fuerzas ucranianas y según él habría
recibido órdenes de otros en el vehículo
de disparar a este hombre cuatro
disparos con sal karadzic off él dijo el
día que se declaró culpable la semana
pasada que no era su intención matarlo
pero esto no ha sido tomado en cuenta
por la corte hoy que lo ha declarado
culpable y le ha dado una sentencia de
cadena
este es la primera sentencia de muchas
que espera el gobierno ucraniano contra
soldados rusos que habrían cometido
atrocidades durante lo que va corrido de
la guerra